ready for a serious case of the
heebie-jeebies Sony Pictures has
released the first official poster for
its upcoming remake reboot sequel The
Grudge and we sincerely hope that you're
not about to jump in the shower the one
sheet references an iconic scene from
the 2004 film that has literally never
stopped giving us the creeps in case
you're not familiar that flick itself a
remake of the 2002 Japanese film Jew
owned the grudge starred Sarah Michelle
Gellar as Karen Davis and American
exchange student in Japan who moves into
a house populated by malevolent spirits
these are no run-of-the-mill spooks
however they're an extra virulent
variety created when one dies under
extraordinarily emotional circumstances
and as the flicks title implies they
don't go away ever in the scene in
question Karen is enjoying a nice hot
shower and is in the middle of washing
her hair when she suddenly appears to
grow an extra hand from the back of her
head it's an incredibly unnerving jump
scare and the fact that the new flicks
producers chose to invoke it for their
movies first poster tells us something
about the specific vein of Terror
they're hoping to mind as the poster
notes Sam Raimi who served as a producer
on the 2004 film and the first of its
two sequels is back in that role for
this go-round he's got an interesting
talent in the director's chair Nicolas
Hesh who turned in Loki slow-burn minor
masterpieces with 2016 eyes of my mother
and 2018 s piercing according to pêche
his film will more than make good on
this posters promise to scare the
absolute hell out of you the director
has explained that he views the grudge
as quote an anthology series featuring
different characters different stories
different locations different ghosts and
while he is taking care to stay true to
what came before he promises that when
it comes to the level of pure terror
he's going for audiences simply aren't
ready Hesh told a crowd at New York
Comic Con the movies way more tough than
the other films in the series not that
the wave of j-horror in the early 2000s
wasn't dumb but this is really dub
peshwa not to explain that he rejects
the reboot label as his
Rudge takes place in the same timeline
at the 2004 movie and he is in no way
simply telling a different version of
the same story
he explained were not rehashing the
first film we're finding the key
elements that are just how The Grudge
expresses itself so much of this movie
is about the fact that this can happen
anywhere and that it happens everywhere
it can spread like wildfire having
certain touchstones was important
obviously with a franchise we don't want
to throw everything out there is certain
stuff that is fun for the fans to see
again in a new context with a new spin
the director also lets slip a few
details about the flicks plot in a
conversation with Entertainment Weekly
it will focus on a police officer played
by Mandy's Andrea Riseborough who
arrives in a new town only to be handed
a bizarre and inexplicable case one
which leads her to investigate a
mysterious house that as pêche describes
it quote has been grudged the director
explained we follow her as well as two
other storylines that are all
interacting with this grudged house in
small-town America like the old films
it's a tapestry of three different
stories that interweave and all take
place at slightly different times
centered around this one house that's at
the center of this case that this cop is
working on that sounds really cool but
we're going to need a bit more
confirmation on the movie sprite factor
let's check in with horror legend Lin
Shaye who is also appearing in the film
and who had a few choice words when
asked about the project in an interview
with comic book Shaye dished wait until
you see this it's the scariest movie
I've ever been a part of not even maybe
not even maybe it's the scariest part
I've ever had Bar None I'm very excited
about it the horror fans are going to go
insane that I can promise okay that's
all we needed
we're officially on board in addition to
riceboro and Shake The Grudge stars
Betty guiltin John Cho William Sadler
and Demi and Bashir the haunting flick
will hit screens on January 3rd 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]